nous sommes devant l'hôpital georges
pompidou fut ici comme ailleurs à partir
de ce 1er janvier vous passerez à la
caisse après tout passage aux urgences
qui ne nécessite pas d'hospitalisation
vous devrez immédiatement réglé en
forfait de 19 euros et 61 centimes non
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
jusqu'à présent il fallait attendre
plusieurs semaines pour recevoir une
facture à son domicile qui variait selon
les actes pratiqués à l'hôpital
l'assurance-maladie s'acquittait de 80%
des frais avec un reste à charge de 20%
pour le patient et saha complémentaires
de santé qui assumait totalement ou
partiellement le remboursement de ces
frais
le but est d'homogénéiser la
participation hospitalière des patients
pour les soins non hospitalisés
actuellement la complexité de la
facturation des urgences d'aujourd'hui
l'illusion de la gratuité pour les
patients et les établissements il ya
toujours eu un reste à charge mais
facturé bien après puis ce reste à
charge est difficile à lire aujourd'hui
ce nouveau forfait patients urgences
devraient être prises en charge par
l'aide médicale d'état ou les
complémentaires santé qui sont
obligatoires pour la majorité des
salariés et dont bénéficient
95% des français pour les 5 autres pour
cent de la population qui sont
généralement des demandeurs d'emploi ou
des retraités c'est un changement
notable à prendre en compte a fortiori
pour les seconds dont l'âge accroît
mécaniquement le recours à l'offre de
soins sur la toile de nombreuses voix
dénoncent une discrimination envers les
plus précaires et un renforcement des
inégalités le coup des 20 euros par
passage aux urgences c'est vraiment un
truc de parisiens débiles qui n'a aucune
idée de ce qu'est un désert médical
et/ou qui n'a jamais eu d'enfant
du coup faudra aller aux urgences que si
tu es sûr d'être en phase terminale à
partir du 1er janvier le personnel
soignant déjà débordé une des urgences
déjà surchargés devra faire passer à la
caisse 19 euros que les patients et
patientes sans mutuelle c'est à dire les
plus précaires payeront plein forfait à
ajouter dans le palmarès des mesures
indigne de ce quinquennat le service des
urgences qui devient payant pour les
personnes n'ayant pas de mutuelle ces
criminels 18 euros c'est plus d'une
semaine de courses alimentaires pour
certaines personnes cette décision va
faire mourir des gens qui nous ont pas
aller se faire soigner un montant unique
de 19 euros 61 pour tous excepté pour
les femmes enceintes de plus de 5 mois
et les personnes atteintes par une
affection de longue durée pour elle le
forfait sera minorée à 8 euros 49 à
noter tout de même mais c'est vraiment
la moindre des choses que les enfants
victimes de sévices les victimes de
terrorisme et les malades du coït dans
le cadre de l'urgence sanitaire seront
pour leur part exemptées des frais reste
que ce dispositif pose aussi des
problèmes de logistique à certains
hôpitaux la nuit par exemple il n'ya pas
toujours de secrétaires médicaux il y à
des infirmiers des aides soignants qui
sont avant tout là pour les soins et
dont ce n'est pas la mission première de
passer une carte bleue les hôpitaux ne
sont pas des supermarchés où il faut
passer à la caisse cette réforme découle
de travaux menés en 2019 à la demande du
premier ministre de l'époque edouard
philippe objectif de ce nouveau
fonctionnement à désengorger les
urgences et réduire les un pays on a des
difficultés pour réunir les informations
est facturé aux bons débiteur et ensuite
des difficultés pour récupérer quand on
a identifié le bon débiteur la somme 213
millions d'euros c'est le montant
facturé aux patients dans les hôpitaux
en france d'après une étude d'impact
seuls 33% sont recouvrées ce nouveau
dispositif pourrait permettre de
récupérer 35 millions d'euros au péril
du principe de la quasi gratuité des
soins sur le territoire français pour
les retraités et les demandeurs d'emploi